ننتقل الى رام الله مع وليد العمري ايضا
لمتابعه الموقف هناك لا سيما ايضا ما
اعلنتها السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وان
كانت هناك لديها اليه او خطه جديده بعد
تطورات نابلس بالامس وليد
السلطه الفلسطينيه كما هو معلوم توجهت الى
المجتمع الدولي وتحديدا الى مجلس الامن من
اجل محاوله اتخاذ قرار بتوفير الحمايه
الدوليه للفلسطينيين في ظل مواصله اسرائيل
وتغولها واستخدامها للقوه الغاشمه ضد
المواطنين الفلسطينيين بعد يوم امس في
نابلس وكذلك بعدما باتا يعرف وكانه سقوط
للتفاهمات التي كانت فرضتها الولايات
المتحده على الجانبين بعد قرارات
الاستيطان الهائله التي اتخذتها حكومه
اقصى اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل التطورات
التي حصلت بالامس لم تبقي اي خيارات لا
للسلطه الفلسطينيه ولا لغيرها وواضح بان
اسرائيل وحكوماتها التي لم تحترم اصلا
اتفاقات مبرمه وموقعه بضمانات دوليه خلال
كل العقود الثلاثه الماضيه هي الان تتصرف
في الضفه الغربيه وكان كل شيء مستباح فيها
بما فيه الدم
ما جرى في نابلس امس
من وجهه نظر الفلسطينيين ونتائجه هو مجزره
كامله احد عشر شهيدا من بينهم ثمانيه
مواطنين عاديين لا علاقه لهم بشيء اكثر من
105 من الجرحى الذين اصيبوا باعايره ناريه
حجم القوات التي استخدمت من قبل قوات
الاحتلال استخدمت في تلك الغاره على مدينه
نابلس كان لافتا بشكل خاص قدر باكثر من
خمسين اليه عسكريه مصفحه مدعمه بوحدات مما
يعرف بكوماندوز المستعربين وهي عناصر من
المخابرات الشباب وكذلك الاستخبارات
العسكريه وعناصر عسكريه في اساسها تتخفى
بالزي المدني بالاضافه الى مروحيات اباتشي
الامريكيه وايضا مسيرات شاركت في كل
العمليه التي استمرت نحو اربع ساعات من
الخطا بمكان ان يوصف ما جرى في نابلس
وكانه كان معركه بين جيش او بين قوتين
عسكريتين في نهايه المطاف هناك جيش احتلال
اغار على هذه المدينه الان اليوم هناك
اضراب شام وشامل وعام في كافه ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه وعلى كافه القطاعات بما فيها
المدارس والجامعات هذا الاضراب ياتي حدادا
وياتي غضبا ايضا غضبا على هذا الوضع
المتدهور وعلى ما شهدته نابلس امس من
عمليات تقتيل
واصابات في داخلها ونابلس تعتبر مدينه
مركزيه في الضفه الغربيه وكذلك يعبر عن
خيبه امل سواء من المواقف المحليه او
العربيه او الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك وليد
العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره حدثنا من رام
الله وش